Chị Tinh Vy Công, chịn Mẹ Wai Đỏ.
Và thực hiện các mê bà biểu dễ khác nhau.
Tụi tôi về khối hợp, lần sau để nhớ thuần thuộc.
Các mẹ Wai vào trong cùm mưa thấy đẹp.
Sao rồi, nhịp nhàng.
Về khách hiếp, đồng tác khó thì tất cả các đồng đồng tác.
Mời đồng tôi về kiai này biểu dễ tải đó.
Đồng tác khó cả.
Mẹ thấp ra chình trong chình hảo nè.
Cứ bình là tất cả cái lồng chiếc không.
Đồng là tổn, lồng chiếc không, lộ chì tổn vài tốt.
Hãy ký nó, điều kện là mạo.
Tốt chưa cầu như mục.
Trời bị tâm lý trong các chuyến bài và các bạn bài và các ngày bài đều đễ.
Cục kì quá trọng của biểu viết phí công.
Đối với giầm vùa, bài trình dễ và tất cả.
Cái nhiều vụ bài hôm nay khác chúng tôi nặt yêu cầu ăn quan là trên hết.
Chỉnh bị thể có một bàn lĩnh trong lý tốt thì viết công,
tôn thuật cả các yêu lĩnh độ tác.
Vìa các ký sự đi, các tình hủng bất trắc có thể sẽ ra.
Mọi gia phí công còn phải nắm được các kia nhiều kia.
Hắc nhau trong quá trình dạ tự kia nữ dung mở bài và nắt miệt là nhiều kia.
Và điện hình thời thiết của cú vực mệt mắt.